the skull crawlers are made to be unique
and horrifying enemies of Kong in Skull
Island but what are the origins of these
nasty creatures Welcome Skull Island is
the second installment of the most of
our cinematic universe following Gareth
Edwards Godzilla in 2014 the movie sets
itself apart from Godzilla by taking
place in 1973 and featuring another
protagonist Titan and other new monsters
while Godzilla and Kong are obviously
the main players of the most of us there
are plenty of other kaiju to contend
with this includes the skull crawlers
who become the major trap of calm skal
Island in fact the reason why calm
attack the army helicopters is that they
were bombing the island awakening the
subterranean skull crawlers from their
nests these creatures were responsible
for wiping out cores family living him
as to the loss of his kind
so the skull crawlers got their name
from the skull like heads and they're
crawling locomotion their true names
known but unspoken by the natives or it
might just be a set of nodding patterns
so the name skull crawler was invented
by Marlowe as he explained their history
to Weaver and Conrad little is known
about the origins of this voracious
predator although its evolutionary
purpose it's abundantly clear the skull
crawler exists to devour destroy and
dominate subterranean in nature
burrowing up to the geologically
unstable steam vents across Skull Island
it is as though the skull crawler climb
out of Hell itself
terrifying this terrifying serpentine is
a hyperbole a creature with such a hyper
adrenalized metabolism that it exists in
a constant state of starvation just as a
shark must keep swimming to survive this
skull crawler must keep feeding
dislocating his own jawbone so as to
maximize its ability to swallow anything
that crosses its path we have observed
different skull crawlers in a wide
variety of different sizes given the
unreachable depths of their subterranean
nesting grounds we have no way of
knowing how big these things might get
or the pecking order that governs their
tribal feeding patterns the skull
crawlers history and Skull Island is
revealed in a vision it says that the
skull crawlers attempted to invade Skull
Island and waged war against calms
ancestors when the Eevee first arrived
on Skull Island the sky
brawler's had wiped up all what two of
the strongest apes which turn out to be
comms parents the Scott Wallace then
attempted to kill Kong's mother while
she was in labor but gongs father kept
them at bay
after calm was born his mother hid him
in a cave and seal it with rocks before
she rushed to aid her maid gone then
watched as his skull crawlers
slaughtered his parents in the
novelization of the king of the mosses
film the Scott Wallace intended to leave
Skull Island upon hearing Ghidorah skull
but they are stopped by calm before they
can do so so that's about everything
known to us about the origins and
history of the skull crawlers let's
discuss their abilities and weaknesses
skull crawlers are very durable as they
can withstand bullets from rifles and
the searing heat of a flamethrower the
largest of the skull braless was only to
be having only two legs and their speed
matches or even surpasses that of an
adult human as the apex predators of
Skull Island the skull crawlers are
fearsome in Delhi in battle using their
jaws full of razor-sharp teeth smaller
skull crawlers are easily
distinguishable from the larger ones
aside from the size obviously their
heads are smaller and more slow they
also possess a more prominent brown skin
tone larger skull crawlers are almost as
big as Kong and they has a more defined
larger and somewhat angle however as
terrifying as they may seem these guys
you do have quite a number of weaknesses
but the main ones being the state of
constant salvation and the two legged
stance makes them prone to be toppled
down that thumb which is used as a
weapon or tool for capturing prey is
vulnerable as any strong opponent could
pull it out like how come did against
the big one regarding the size of these
creatures the smaller ones have a height
of around 12 feet while the big one was
stated to be 95 feet tall but looked
more like in the range of 70 in front of
calm their weight also varies from 10 to
a hundred tons but the big one could
have easily been in the range of 500
tons
easily since their kind wipe out Kong
species and there is a very large
subterranean cavity underneath Skull
Island there might be a probability of
bigger skull crawlers in hibernation so
thank you for watching this video and do
subscribe
more monster and kaiju related content
also put in your thoughts in the comment
section